[Music]
in 1849
in the ancient city of nineveh in
northern iraq
archaeologists sifted through dusty
remains
hoping to find records to prove that
bible stories were true
what they found instead was one of the
oldest libraries
in the world inscribed on crumbling clay
tablets was a 4
000 year old story so riveting
the first person to translate it started
stripping
from excitement called the epic
of gilgamesh the story starts with
gilgamesh
king of the city of uruk crashing every
wedding
and sleeping with the bride before she
has a chance to sleep with her husband
to tame gilgamesh the goddess aruru
created a rival called enkidu
enkidu lived beyond the walls of the
city where chaos reigned
and wild animals invaders and evil
spirits
prowled after a priestess of the goddess
ishtar seduced enkidu
the wild animals beyond the wall
rejected him
and he ventured into the city there he
encountered gilgamesh
up to his usual tricks enkidu stepped in
to stop him
almost perfectly matched the two men
wrestled all
through the city streets until gilgamesh
won the fight
by a hare afterwards they were
inseparable
with his new friend gilgamesh turned his
attention from the brides of uruk
to proving his strength in combat they
set out
to slay humbaba a creature with a
thousand faces
who guarded the trees of the forest of
cedar
they tracked humber and ambushed him
cornered he begged for his life
then cursed them as gilgamesh dealt the
final blow
back home in uruk the goddess ishtar
took a romantic
interest in gilgamesh knowing she tended
to lose interest and
curse her former flames gilgamesh
refused
her advances so ishtar unleashed the
bull
of heaven on uruk to destroy crops and
kill people when gilgamesh and enkidu
slayed the creature defending the city
the gods killed enkidu he entered
the house of dust the shadowy
mesopotamian
underworld where the spirits of the dead
knelt
eternally on the ground eating dirt and
drinking
stone grieving for enkidu and terrified
of meeting this fate himself
gilgamesh set off beyond the cosmic
mountains
to seek immortality he passed
scorpion people and groves of gemstone
trees
traveled beneath the mountains and
outran the rising sun
until he finally came to the end of the
world
where he found a bar the bartender was a
goddess named shiduri
who urged gilgamesh to give up his quest
she told him all mortals must die
but until death comes he should enjoy
his life
but gilgamesh refused to give up
reluctantly shidori gave him directions
to cross the waters of death
and meet the immortal man atnapishtim
the gods had granted atnapishtim
immortality following a great flood
during which he'd built a boat loaded
two of every animal onto it
and landed on a mountain peak
atnapishtim
also encouraged gilgamesh to accept that
death comes for everyone
but gilgamesh still would not budge so
adna pishtim told him that if he could
conquer
sleep the gods might grant him
immortality
gilgamesh intended to stay awake for
seven days
but fell asleep immediately adnapishdim
then told him about a magical plant
that grew at the bottom of the ocean and
granted
eternal youth though gilgamesh
successfully retrieved the plant
a snake stole it on his way home but
when gilgamesh laid eyes on his
beautiful city again
he made peace with his mortality and
vowed to spend his lifetime
doing great deeds he wrote his story
on a lapis lazuli tablet and buried it
under the city walls for future
generations to find
and learn from the tablets uncovered in
nineveh were part of the library of the
assyrian king
ashobanipal though the story is mythical
gilgamesh was probably a real king of
uruk
versions of his tail date to 2000
bce and perhaps even longer ago
and still echo through literature today
in the nearby sumerian city of uh lived
a high priestess and princess
whose epic poems would influence the
likes of homer
and the hebrew old testament learn more
about history's first author
with this video